On June 1st, President Donald Trump
issued a message. Here are a few
excerpts.
Quote, "Today, I joined the Coptic
Orthodox Christian community in
observing Global Coptic Day. Tracing its
roots to St. Mark, the Apostle of Jesus
Christ and evangelist who brought the
Christian faith to Egypt in the first
century, the Coptic Church has been a
beacon of Christendom in Africa for
nearly 2,000 years. The Coptic community
has left an indelible mark on the hearts
of millions of Christians, most
evidently seen in their timeless
contributions to Christian theology and
culture. This global Coptic day, we also
pause to reflect upon the vicious and
ongoing persecution of Coptic Orthodox
Christians in Africa and across the
Middle East. In 2015, 21 Coptic
construction workers were brutally
executed by ISIS terrorists in Libya.
Like persecuted Christians all around
the world, these heroic martyrs refused
to renounce their faith. They
exemplified their sacrificial love and
steadfast devotion to God, even in the
face of certain death. The cops
persistence amid relentless persecution
is a living testament to their
unbreakable resolve and fearless
dedication to spreading the gospel of
Jesus Christ.
And this relentless persecution
continues even as we speak. Just last
Saturday, June 7th, yet another Coptic
church went up in flames in Muslim
Egypt, the Virgin Mary Church in Luxor.
If you're not aware, every few weeks or
so, a Coptic church catches fire in
Egypt with the authorities immediately
and automatically ruling out arson. And
this is to say nothing also about the
endemic disappearance of Coptic
Christian girls and women off the
streets of Egypt. The latest most
high-profile case being that of Mariam
Mitat Remy and occurred just about two
weeks ago. Then there are the regular
uprisings and collective punishments of
Christians whenever one of their numbers
is perceived as getting too uppidity for
an infidel. All last week in Minya,
Muslims rioted, destroying and burning
dozens of Christian homes, all while
hollering Allah Akbar. Why? Because one
cop had the audacity of trying to
install a mobile booster on his roof,
which was somehow deemed offensive to
Islam. At any rate, Trump's message to
Egypt's Christians is a reminder that he
is the only president in modern times,
certainly when compared to his
predecessors who actually acknowledges
the plight of Christians under Islam.
Nor is this a new development. Trump
spoke like this even in his first term.
In 2020, Trump issued a statement noting
the quote ongoing challenges facing the
largest Christian group in the Middle
East, meaning the cops. He added that it
is quote time for us to acknowledge the
importance of religious freedom and
reaffirm our commitment to promoting and
defending this core tenant of a free
society. Tragically, far too many people
the world over face persecution on
account of their faith. That's the end
of his quote. That same year, 2020,
Trump called the treatment of Christians
in the Middle East quote beyond
disgraceful, adding that Christianity
was being quote treated horribly and
very unfairly and it's criminal. Perhaps
most notably in May 2017 after Islamic
gunman massacred 28 Coptic Christians,
10 of whom were children who were all
traveling home after visiting a
monastery. Trump said,
quote, "This merciless slaughter of
Christians in Egypt tears at our hearts
and grieves our souls. America makes
clear to its friends, allies, and
partners that the treasured and historic
Christian communities of the Middle East
must be defended and protected. The
bloodletting of Christians must end, and
all who aid their killers must be
punished. Now, it may be argued that all
that Trump is really doing is speaking
some words. Even so, the fact remains
words do matter, and the proof of that
can be seen in that Trump's
predecessors, Joe Biden and Barack
Obama, always spoke the opposite kind of
words. For example, at the height of the
worst state sanctioned terrorist attack
on Egypt's Coptic Christians in modern
history, the 2011 Maspiro massacre, when
the government shot at and ran over with
tanks dozens of cops for daring to
protest the burnings and closures of
their churches, Obama issued what his
White House presented as a quote
pointedly even-handed statement that
calls equally on Christians and the
military to show restraint.
Because, you know, Egypt's belleaguered
Christian minorities needed to restrain
themselves against the tanks that were
chasing them down and running them over,
turning many of them into pancakes.
Literally, we have the pictures. Egypt's
unarmed Christians, Obama is suggesting
or was suggesting, had to restrain
themselves against the Egyptian
military, which opened a non-stop hail
of bullets on them, also while screaming
Allah Akbar. And we have the videotapes.
This, of course, was par for the course.
For Obama and his ilk, Christians can
never be persecuted. That would run
completely a foul of their narrative,
which sees Christians unequivocally as
oppressors and non-Christians as the
oppressed in every circumstance, past
and present. Thus, when Muslims bombed
three churches in Sri Lanka on Easter
Sunday in 2019, killing some 300
Christians, Obama and Hillary Clinton
could not even bring themselves to
identify the slain victims as
Christians, the way they most certainly
would have had the perpetrators been
Christian and the victims Muslim.
Instead, they condemned a terror attack
on Easter worshippers. That was the only
way they would ever identify the slain
Christians. In fact, not only did Obama
fail to acknowledge, much less do
anything about the Muslim persecution of
Christians, he aided and embedded it.
See numerous old articles and documented
reports I wrote starting way back in
2012 in this video's description. In
other words, there is a reason that
Donald Trump has repeatedly asserted
that quote, "President Obama is the
founder of ISIS." But it is perhaps in
the context of Nigeria where a bonafide
genocide of Christians has been taking
place since the year Obama first entered
the White House that the differences
between Obama and Biden on the one hand
and Trump on the other emerge most
clearly. Keep in mind that on average a
Nigerian Christian is killed for his or
her faith every two hours.
Although jihadists slaughtered and
terrorized Nigeria's Christians all
during Obama's 8-year tenure, and
although the United States Commission on
International Religious Freedom had,
beginning in 2009 and every year
afterwards, repeatedly urged the State
Department to designate Nigeria as a
country of particular concern, that is,
nations that quote engage in or tolerate
violations of religious freedom. The
Obama administration refused. Under
Hillary Clinton, the State Department
went so far as to refuse to even
designate Boo Haram as a terrorist
organization, even though it is a
notorious jihadist group that has
slaughtered more Christians and bombed
more churches than the Islamic State in
Iraq and Syria combined. It was only in
2020 under the Trump administration that
Nigeria was finally designated as a
country of particular concern. Moreover,
with characteristic bluntness, Trump
once forthrightly asked Nigerian
President Muhammadu Buuhari, whom many
Nigerian officials say Obama helped
bring to power, quote, "Why are you
killing Christians?" Trump asked him.
Once Biden and Harris got into office,
however, it was business as usual. In
2021, the State Department under Anthony
Blinken went out of its way to remove
Nigeria from the countries of particular
concern list. At the time, many
observers responded by slamming the
Biden administration. As one human
rights lawyer, Shawn Nelson, noted,
quote, "Outcate department's removal of
country of particular concern status for
Nigeria's religious freedom violations
is entirely warranted. No explanations
have been given that could justify this
decision. If anything, the situation in
Nigeria has grown worse over the last
year. Thousands of Christians are
targeted, killed, and kidnapped, and the
government is simply unwilling to stop
these atrocities. Removing country of
particular concern status for Nigeria
will only embolden the increasingly
authoritarian government there. In
short, at a time when lies from the
highest places are everywhere
suffocating the truth, yes, words such
as Donald Trump's words about Christian
persecution do matter and are a first
necessary step to addressing any
problem.
[Music]